what first pops into your mind when you
hear the word
midlife crisis yes the dreaded midlife
crisis is the but of all kinds of jokes
but it's also a serious matter after I
lost a few friends to midlife suicide I
decided to create an alternative
narrative to the awful way we tend to
think of our 40s 50s and 60s and I'm
going to share that with you over the
next 3 minutes life is one of three life
stages that sprouted in the 20th century
adolescence didn't even exist until 1904
when Society realized that just because
you hit puberty didn't me mean you were
an adult retirement was popularized
nearly a century ago with pensions and
Social Security uh and then 25 years
later with the Advent of a ARP I hope
you have your card um and retirement
communities those those two life stages
got a whole lot of love but there's a
life stage in the middle that didn't get
much respect midlife is the natural
outgrowth of the three decades of
additional longevity we were granted in
the 20th century but all it got was a
bad brand the midlife crisis which was
coined in
1965 yet research on how happiness
evolves as we age shows that from about
age 22 or 23 all the way to 45 to 50
there is a long slow decline in life
satisfaction it bottoms out around 45 to
50 although your mileage may
vary um on the other side of that though
the good news is that from age 50 on uh
we get happier and happier it's called
the UK curve of Happiness so maybe
there's a new framework to think about
midlife one that we learned when we were
kids the magical metamorphosis of the
caterpillar to the
butterfly just as a caterpillar eat eats
incessantly uh as just before it's about
to spin its chrystus so do we as young
adults madly consume and
produce and then the the caterpillar
decides to take its midlife break in its
Crysis which is dark and gooey and
solitary but it's also where the
transformation happens on the other side
of that there's a Crysis that cracks
open and this beautiful winged creature
emerges that Delights us all
the butterfly so to recap the
caterpillar consumes the Crysis
transforms and the Butterfly
pollinates what if we rethought midlife
such that it's not a crisis it's a
Crysis the midlife
Chrysalis what if we thought of midlife
as the dawning of a new age an age where
much of what we accumulated
dissolves just as we're ready to
transform
spread our wings and pollinate our
wisdom to the world in our 50s and
Beyond if you yes yes if you look at
life like that it's maybe possible that
it's cool to grow old are we ready for
pro-aging not Anti-aging
products can we make aging
aspirational I sure hope so thank
you
w